it's great to welcome to the program
today Hannah gurmann who is a professor
of US history and American Studies at
New York University's Gallatin school of
individualized study she has been
working on the issue of whistleblowers
and leakers in the United States and
around the world and first of all thanks
for joining me a Hannah really
appreciate it
thanks for having me so we get a lot of
our understanding of whistleblowers and
leakers from reports in the media in the
United States and that those reports may
not always completely precisely convey
the difference between a whistleblower
and a leaker so let's maybe start there
how should the audience be thinking
about the difference between the two
terms right well I'm glad you asked that
question because I think part of what
makes it really difficult to even begin
a conversation about whistleblowing is
lack of consensus on the terms and a
tendency to conflate we whistleblowing
and leaking so leaking is endemic to the
state right so politicians will on an
everyday basis leaked to the media
however when something happens a
disclosure that they don't like they'll
use the term leaked often as a way to
discredit that disclosure on the other
hand whistleblowing is what happens when
somebody discloses information to the
public with an eye towards the public
interest with an eye towards changing
policy as a form of protest as a form of
dissent so very different from the
everyday tactics and political
maneuvering that happens among senior
policymakers on an everyday basis yes so
I mean that sounds great in terms of a
distinction but I think people will
immediately realize that much of that is
open to interpretation in terms of
whether you so I guess one thing that
comes to mind to me is when you call
something a leak you're implying the
focus should be on the fact that
information was released that shouldn't
have been as the sort of most important
characteristic when you call something
whistleblowing
you're shifting the focus not to
how we learned about it but to the
importance of the content in what was
released and there's certainly some
subjectivity there yes I think that's a
key point and so this is a political
terrain how one identify something as a
leak or as a form of whistleblowing and
to your first point it really is the
state and those who oppose such
disclosures that will pretty much
inevitably say this is a form of
unauthorized disclosure because when
information is classified secret it is
illegal to disclose whistleblowers take
it upon themselves to disclose that
information because they believe that it
is important and in the public interest
for people to know so yes this is going
to be a constant struggle there's no
science it is a political act to
identify somebody as a whistleblower and
it is important to say that the content
matters right I mean when Daniel
Ellsberg who disclosed the Pentagon
Papers in 1971 did what he did
the Supreme Court decided that the
content was important enough that the
American people and the world needed to
know it's a complicated case because the
press was allowed to publish although
Daniel Ellsberg's case ended in a
mistrial so we'll never actually know
how the courts would have decided there
was somewhere I read I don't remember
exactly where which attempted to draw a
distinction between leaking and
whistleblowing on the grounds that
whistleblowing is exposing activity that
is illegal but that actually seems a bit
a bit too simplistic for me I mean what
you could say well Chelsea Manning
exposed crimes that were being committed
allegedly committed by members of the
American military Edward Snowden exposed
practices that while maybe unsavory
maybe not productive to the national
security of the United States as our
intelligence agencies might claim they
were legal sort of by statute I mean we
decide what's legal illegal and what
isn't legal so I'm wondering whether the
lagaa
of what's exposed is relevant or whether
it's a distraction or somewhere in
between right it's probably somewhere in
between because there are whistleblowers
who do expose gross illegalities waste
fraud abuse and those things fall more
classically into a whistleblowing
paradigm as it's developed within a body
of statutory and regulatory law but a
lot of the most important disclosures
made by national security whistleblowers
as you say would not be considered legal
in well fundamentally because the very
act of disclosing is illegal and then
also as you mentioned because the
national security state is so powerful
it has an army of lawyers that make a
body of law to justify its actions so I
do think it can be a slippery slope well
you have really great lawyers who are
working on these issues the law can't
and shouldn't be the only terrain on
which we're talking and thinking about
and defending whistleblowers and I do
support the idea of thinking about
whistleblowers in the longer tradition
of civil disobedience while some are
clearly obeying the law others choose to
break the law in the name of a higher
purpose so there's a big connection
between how whistleblowers and leakers
are treated by an administration or a
government and issues of press freedom
and defending the the press I want to
think back a little bit to prior
administrations one of my I had many
criticisms from the left of the Obama
administration we could talk about the
drone program for example not what we're
talking about today but there are there
are many criticisms of the Obama
administration in terms of how they
dealt with whistleblowers and leakers do
you have any overall or overarching
themes that you've identified in terms
of how Democratic versus Republican
administrations deal with whistleblowers
and leakers or is there not a material
difference between the two
that's a great question I think this has
less to do with distinctions between
Republicans and Democrats than with
executive power and so you have under
the Carter Administration for example a
huge ramping up of the use of
non-disclosure agreements many cases
that went to court to censor national
security employees when were in books
during the period so Carter a Democrat
somebody who you maybe you might imagine
had different views on national security
but still very much clamping down on the
First Amendment rights of national
security employees and very much
denying whistleblower status to a whole
array of individuals that should be
considered whistleblowers so while there
have been some major crackdowns that
have happened
under Republicans Nixon obviously
charging Ellsberg under the Espionage
Act I I think and I think overall this
is not a partisan distinction but much
more one of presidential power and
executive power can you talk a little
bit you talked about whistleblower
status can you talk about what that
means and how this relates to how
individuals who release information are
handled both by by the government and
the justice system sure and well
whistleblower status is denied to most
individuals to disclose to pretty much
anybody who just closes classified
information or anything related to
national security so there's a very
narrow scope in which anybody who does
kind of try to report these wrongs would
be considered a whistleblower and that
through a series of internal channels
that have been developed in recent years
and so Obama for example said you know
Snowden could have used internal
channels but
history of those channels is is is not
one that should give us much confidence
in them there's a lot of evidence that
they're used that they're not only
ineffective but that they become modes
of retaliation against people who try to
disclose wrongdoing so anybody who goes
outside of those channels is not
officially by the state considering a
whistleblower and so they don't really
have a lot to stand on in a court of law
in addition if their case were to go to
trial they are not in a position to
defend themselves using the classified
evidence in which they were trying to
expose gross wrongdoing so their hands
are pretty tied and it's really hard to
kind of imagine how this would play out
in a formal system of justice in any way
that serves justice to either the
whistleblower or to the public who's
benefiting from those disclosures so let
me make sure I understand that because
that seems like a key point if you are
indicted and charged with crimes related
to information that you made public that
had classified or other protected status
you might imagine that it would be
influential to a jury for example to
hear the content of what it was that you
were trying to expose it might be crimes
it might be obvious gross wrongdoing as
you suggest but you would not be able to
use that as a defense because of the way
that that information is itself
classified which effectively ties your
hands in terms of how to strongly defend
yourself in a court of law
exactly yeah and and there is no in
other words there is no Public Interest
defense that would be a defense where
you would be able to use that material
to show that yes well you broke the law
you did so in the name of the public
interest and you would try to prove that
what you had done was in the public
interest right now there is no such
thing there are
a body of lawyers that are working to
develop a public interest defense at an
international scale but it's very hard
to imagine that that would happen
anytime soon so let's talk now or tie
this in to press freedom in the sort of
tail end of our conversation journalists
reporters analysts all sorts of
different people that work in media
regularly are in touch with sources of
different kinds sometimes their sources
that might be considered leakers when we
hear something that went on in the
hallway outside of the Oval Office for
example sometimes the sources might at
least colloquially be called
whistleblowers even if they don't have
that formal status can you kind of
connect government policy towards
whistleblowers and leakers to the
fundamental issue of Press Freedom and
the duty to report for journalists and
reporters yes I think it cannot be
understated how important whistleblowers
are to a Free Press
it's really a symbiotic relationship and
in the course of researching the history
of national security whistleblowing this
theme has just been confirmed time and
again you you can't have the kind of
investigative reporting that one needs
on the national security state without
insiders and without people who are
willing to expose the kinds of secrets
that we are not otherwise privy to so if
you don't have whistleblowers you don't
really have a free press and it's a
complicated history but we live in a
situation in which the press has the
right to publish but the people who are
disclosing the information don't have
the right to disclose it and that is an
insane paradox that has to be somehow
resolved otherwise we really don't have
First Amendment rights in this country
for the millions of people who do have
access to classified information yet
sort of strikes me as the the
circumstances that at some point in
different states existed with marijuana
which was it's not illegal to have some
of it but you're not allowed to buy it
and you're not
to grow it so then how did you obtain it
in the first place and it seems that a
lot of journalists and reporters are put
in this very strange situation like that
yeah yeah an increasingly journalists
who had previously thought that this
kind of irony benefited them that they
were safe increasingly see that the
sanctions that have been put up against
whistleblowers are increasingly
threatening the press as well can you
talk about how that works because you're
right that there was this idea that once
you had the information even if the
person who gave it to you didn't do so
legally you now are protected or
shielded in some way as a member of the
media that that's not always the case
yeah I mean well there have been some
famous instances considering for example
Judy Miller from the New York Times when
she refused to disclose her source she
was threatened with contempt of court
and did in fact go to jail so that's one
aspect of it and also increasingly in
the Trump administration you have even
more direct threats about press
censorship and the threat of actually
taking journalists to court and
potentially trying them for publishing
classified information absolutely
important issue I'm really glad that
professor Hannah gurmann US history and
American studies professor at New York
University was able to join us and talk
about this Hannah really appreciate your
time today thanks for having me